[Music]
in unexpected couple News bad-boy rocker
Tommy Lee is apparently hooking up with
a digital star Brittany Furlan oh yeah
my boyfriend go dogs caught the possible
couple making out in Calabasas
California on Wednesday night following
a sushi dinner date 30 year old Brittany
wrapped her arms around 53 year old
Tommy's neck as he grabbed on to her
backside et has reached out to reps for
both stars to find out exactly what's
going on be more like what the heck
Brittany was one of vines first big
stars and has since parlayed that fame
into mainstream acting work hard sucks
Elle is dead I Sarah she was previously
engaged to filmmaker Randall Kirk ii and
later dated Kong Skull Island director
Jordan white Roberts a dome lid
as for tommylee he was most recently
linked to singer Sofia tofa they were
engaged in 2014 of course before that he
was married to Heather Locklear and
Pamela Anderson with whom he shares two
sons 21 year old Brandon and 19 year old
Dylan
[Music]